le
mais
alors là le pôle technique en fait ça
regroupe la maintenance des véhicules la
maintenance des remontées mécaniques et
la maintenance de neige de culture nous
en dameuse on a onze dameuse ici on a
trois engins lourds pour le déneigement
on a six motoneige et une quinzaine de
véhicules roulant donc moi je suis
responsable de la partie damages et
véhicules
on a du personnel à l'année et on a des
saisonniers bien sûr pour compléter les
équipes univers
plus
hollywood sommeillant
oui sa part à
tombé qui donc
personne nous fasse une farce qui est
charges de sous
les deux machines sans fil de l'eau à la
dôle jura à la dôle il ya une machine à
trier une machine standard entrailles
la machine un treuil a de fait toutes
les pistes qui sont
à trieste où il ya un peu plus de pente
où il faut de l'année j'ai rapporté moi
j'étais un
pendant qu'en de 37 ans
massip de la dôle contact permanent
était maintenant je traite des vaches
tous ces boutons mais servent tous il ya
tout ce qui est lié par lasser le
réglage des rétroviseurs
c'est ce qu'est dégivrage pare brise
d'une et arrière vitres latérales
vers l'autre l'autre jour on avait huit
g8 au sommet au moins septembre
on a toujours on a toujours un problème
devant ça use l'année j'ai même une fois
qu'elle est tombée le vent le vent usa
neigeux
aux amplitudes que j'ai eue là c'était 4
degrés au sommet - 24 euros
oui toute la vallée du rhône lac léman
au mieux ces nouveaux on va l'y faire un
pisse de montée du liziec c'est tendu
s'est pris à partie on déroule un petit
bout de temps pour s'accroche à
l'ancrage content car
[Musique]
après la tourelle
dutreuilh reste libre on travaille
pratiquement normalement avec la dameuse
tout en sachant qu'on
accroché
[Musique]
cette année j'ai un peu eu match
des dogons
[Musique]
et